SOESE PA NEED TO
NG
ONITN OU
WEULD HAHEAS A
CODER SED GANATE AE BLOCD
IT. PEOPLDEE TO .
THE ANNV WHO DIDMUE  ACCOUNTABLE
NOARTISAN, THAT IS BER.
THS S THAT GET
FACTS WHERY LEADVERY OPPTU
EAMPEVE TANDINON.Y THEDTWO REPU.
E REJECTEDO MAY  M
THAT LED TJA6tWHDILI
HIS OVER THE
S DEMOIS NOT TLY.
DEALING WITTH
INVESTIGIO
TI MFORWARE IDEA TIHE CAPITICABM
S THOS
ACCOUNTABLE WH THS
AGAIN.E DESE
STIGATION YOU CAAT
NT GIVEN NO
BUT YOURSELF WILL IPATE?
>> C HAVA ARTISAS.THFATHERE ARE
TAK DTOCTED TERS
E RHIS
OF THE OFFICE THAT WE HO AF  BEY
RTHY.
>> DYORSONAL
IS APE
EX
DO YOURVKER INMATH OF HIS  IN.
>> I THINK THARSON WHO
N LINE TT DEMONSTRAT
COMMITMENT TO CONSTITUTION
>> ARE THERETH AT YOU HY T
OUIEVE S INVESTION? NOT
TO MREICTHE VAST MAJORITY OF IC
CT BASED
INR S E IC PREVENT
OM
REE WILL
>> THE REPLI T C G AN FROE BEGI?
>>OL
INTTEE HAS BEE
N  WE
IN FACT, TREAN
PEN  WE  T
MINOTYY AN
BLOCKED IT.ENA
IPTIOLEFTLIT OA TO ON
ABOVD ING TH
INVESTIGATION TSTH HER
EF
THANK YOU.U..
T LIEDBL TSE
INVESTIGATESHAIS GO BACK.ALL HR
LEAS WALKINGT TA LET'SAC
CONGRESSMA.
T,
S WARCUS AFTER THEMISSION WA
VO.
, DOES THAT
S  -- N McCARTHYL FRAME E
Y  WAY. COMMITTE
EXTRAORDINARY IT I SEE LRMER NR
TAKE
CATHE TI NDH SAT NCY DO.ALLY OUE
EAKER.
A COUPLES O HER PARTNER INDERSH
>>GRESS TEE RIW. STANDING ALBYTT
THAT?
E' HERE.CAN BE A HE MINORITYEA
ATSAID.
Y PELOSI SHOULD BE CALLING
SINGER, FRED, DAN OULDER REAL
NVESTIGATION.
T ATPELOSI.
DON'T U VE
ALY HABE
T ISE WORKS.
THE CHALLEFO ARESERVE ONT COMMIR
T
>> CHARLIE, JOHN HAS ALREADY D W
WILLING TOVEIS
.
E DIFFERENT .
WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT PLACE NOW.
ACM.
YS ALL OF
REPUBLICANORE-ELECTION.
E R ARLLY, IT'S INTO ON THIS
WHOW FI THE
KEE LEMONA OUT